previously on stardom I founded a
startup called not Viacom where you can
share 6.1 second videos I then brought
in through my friends to help me build
the most innovative video platform and I
met up with Aria we secretly hate each
other and constantly compare a dick size
it's just so bad I'm just relaxing now
trying to figure out what you do next
[Music]
yeah I'm excited but I'm also afraid
it's just getting really hard you know
managing all these relationships at once
it's getting too hard what excites you
about the relationship you have with
your employees wait what no I was
talking with my tinder relationship God
never listen to me
but to be honest I just can't get Ari
off my mind
whose aria nice he's just some startup
founder we recently played chess just
started founder I think it means more to
you than that we used to be best friends
but then things changed things really
changed can you tell me a little bit
about your relationship with Joe ma you
know we were friends then best friends
even how'd you guys meet he was in the
study room struggling with a simple
assignment but I knew he was smarter
than that he came up to me offering his
help
thank God cuz I just couldn't focus I
was about to give up something else was
consuming him I could see that he was
pretty broken at the time so I thought I
could bring him under my wing I gave him
a better place to stay better resources
better contacts a better life nobody
wanted to give him a chance but I saw
the potential in him he was kind to me
extremely kind I didn't serve it
let me stay with him in this apartment
he gave me my own room he even got me
all the textbooks I needed for school he
really took me out of the dumps you know
even guided me through my academic
career without him I would have been
lost he's the reason why I am Who I am
today from algorithms that statistics to
cryptocurrencies he taught me everything
he made sure I knew the right things he
made sure I succeeded you would have
been nothing without me
all those internships he got those
through me except Microsoft that was
more him that's thoughtful I wanted the
best for him I really did I did
everything that good for him
until yesterday
what happened I should have known
I feel so stupid okay back
[Music]
I just couldn't face the truth
[Music]
I don't know I mean you just changed I
used to be kind and warm but I think one
day I just realized that he wasn't a
selfless person I thought he was
even kick me out of the house I mean I
appreciate everything he's done for me
then we come on man where the [ __ ] was I
supposed to go I knew I had nothing
you know I should have known people like
him they don't have people like me
[Music]
how did you feel it was a humiliating
I miss aria I really do
even if he had Xterra motives to bring
me in I was really happy I still am oh
wait wanted from me but obviously I
didn't have it anymore
that's why just pushed me away I didn't
ask why I mean I didn't deserve his
kindness but things just got worse and
that's where he crossed the line
I've never confronted him about it
because it just wouldn't matter
I want his apology I just wanted to
break
while making him feel the pain that I
felt until he's completely broken and
they can regret everything that he did
[Music]
alright guys so today I get a consultant
to make this video for us it's gonna
tell us you know how to think about MVPs
so what's the MVP
you mean like LeBron wait what's a
LeBron oh he's the MVP alright whatever
alright let's just play the video so the
biggest problem that startups run into
is creating something that nobody wants
to buy this Way's years of work and
thousands of dollars only to leave you
broken unemployed just like a college
degree so to stop this from happening I
thought I'd go over the concept of an
MVP and how this can help you grow your
company so what is an MVP this often
gets confused with most valuable player
but I think that comparison is kind of
unfair because if you're trying to start
a startup chances are you have zero
athletic ability instead MVP here means
minimum viable product a rough version
of your idea that takes a minimal amount
of effort but it's still good enough
that users can get a taste of the full
product similar to how dating someone is
sort of a taste of what marriage will be
like and in my case I've been told I
taste like insecurity and an absentee
father now the reason you want to build
an MVP is because it lets you learn what
your customers like and don't like as
quickly as possible this is a pretty
important concept because 90% of
startups fail because they have no clue
what their customers want like this one
time I was sitting at McDonald's and
thought of a really good app idea it
involved the dating app where girls
would choose guys based only on their
personality and finally give nice guys a
fighting chance but then I asked myself
would I date someone based only on the
personality I'll let you decide now I'm
sure you're wondering what an MVP looks
like the answer to that depends on what
you're trying to build so I thought it'd
be helpful to show a few real-life
examples let's say you wanted to build
an app where people could store and
share files online you could do one of
two things one quit your job and spend
years trying to make the app yourself or
to hire someone to create a 30-second
video
what that app would look like and show
it to investors for millions of dollars
while option 1 sounds attractive the MVP
here is too and that's what Dropbox did
well let's say you wanted to figure out
if a girl a guy liked you your MVP here
would be a small low pressure invite
like hey I'm going out to dinner with
friend do you want to come along we're
grabbing pizza smiley face and a few
things can happen here one she won't
respond to you two she says something
short like haha or lol or three she says
no I thought I told you I'm not
interested when this happens you might
try to convince yourself that she's
still into you but chances are she is
into you so just wait a few days and try
again so by now you're probably
wondering how to actually build an MVP
and that's exactly what I'm going to
show you now the steps I'll be outlining
might seem simple at first but there's a
bit of math involved so you'll need to
pay close attention and just before we
start I thought I should mention that
these steps are approved by the
International Board of start-up venture
capitalists which means rest assured
it's coming from a source of authority
so without further ado here are the
steps to building your first MVP step 1
don't we have enough startups already
so I hope that was helpful and best of
luck in your startup journey all right
so what do you guys think we need to
start off by building our back-end
infrastructure we can leverage Amazon
see DNS load balancers and lambdas
modularize our infrastructure by using
micro services so they can set up
elastic scaling and save money I don't
think we should do that it's the most
cost efficient solution well we don't
even know if we're going to get that
many users it's a total overkill yes it
might save some capital but development
time is our most limited resource and we
can't waste time thinking about
scalability on an MVP right now our most
limited resource is my patience with
your shitty ideas why can't we just have
a Facebook page and let people post
their videos there and see if that grows
that's actually a really good and smart
MVP but for the sake of this web series
we have to do something more complicated
all right so here's what we're gonna do
wait what do you have the final thing
because I went to Waterloo all right
here's the fun
so as an MVP we're just gonna make a
purely consumption site the reason why
is because we want to validate if
there's actually the mat for our website
so that's why we're just gonna make a
simple web app what we'll do is that
we'll pretend that invite only to be
able to produce on our platform but in
reality we don't have a production side
but we're really gonna do it is just
that we're going to steal old find
videos and post them on our website that
way the consumer side will think that
we're producing videos using the mobile
app which is invite for growth we'll
have a Facebook page and we'll put only
the best of the best vine videos there
and then we'll just Bruce the [ __ ] out
of it with ad credits all right so
here's what we need we need someone to
build the whole web app front and
back-end
we don't have enough resource to
separate them that's why we need someone
to own the whole full stack come on it
all right who wants to write the crawler
to get all the best vine videos and then
write pipelines to funnel them in
website Connie John can write the fake
nine in page for a mobile website and
also can you set up the CDN so it could
serve videos faster and I'll manage a
Facebook page and start growing it all
right let's do it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right what do you think of this no
we can't launch that looks exactly like
the no this is perfect
all right guys this is really good all
right so next we're not you I think you
might want to look at this
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
it's not good
[Music]
what's poppin so I hope you enjoyed this
episode I definitely had fun making it
as I hope you guys had fun watching it I
just want to give a shout out to Matthew
Cho he's my new cinematographer he's
amazing so I want you guys to check out
his stuff because um I don't know he's
probably one of the best in the
mythographers I've ever met and yeah he
deserve a shout out second shout out
I want a shout out to the sinful
engineer thank you for giving me that
clip about MVP this guy's hilarious yes
you should check that out I put his link
on the description and also of course if
you liked this video and you haven't
subscribed to my channel subscribe now
come on were you waiting for and yeah
thank you so much and see you on the
next episode peace